two years ago I retired I had free time
and wanted to explore we traveled and
explored the California Central
Coast and I explored what's new in the
market simply learns data science boot
camp in association with Caltech helped
me learn new
skills so I unretired this year and
started my own Consulting
by the name of CMR solutions
group hi my name is Cindy Reid and I
live in
California I've been a leader in
information technology for three
decades after 30 years of working I
decided to take a break I retired from
the post of senior director at
mindbody I worked on myself and I worked
on some plans for my
future meanwhile I decided to learn more
about data science so I opted for simply
learned data science boot camp in
association with Caltech ctme
program my overall experience was
excellent I especially liked the online
portal and access to the lab and the
knowledge
base in addition the instructors were
very
knowledgeable the program helped me
extand and broaden my understanding of
data science I now feel well equipped
with multiple tools and applications of
data
science we recently got a chance to
visit the Caltech
campus it was
exhilarating the speakers and topics
were so meaningful to hear the current
research that they're doing as well as
be able to connect with our course
learning and the
experience it was also really nice to
connect with my
peers we also received special access to
a behind the scenes tour at Nasa
JP the highlight of the tour was getting
to see the control room the very control
room where the Mars rover mission was
being
conducted I went back to work recently
and I set up my own Str iic management
consultancy firm called CMR solutions
group I feel that there's no dirth of
opportunities and in fact you can create
your own if you have the right attitude
and you're willing to up
skill